Jessica Jones season one was my favorite
Marvel TV shows handling highly
provocative themes such as rape and
sexual harassment it perfectly
encapsulated the me2 and types of
movement way before either of those
issues were at the forefront of the
media what the show demonstrated was a
man that had manipulated women to carry
out all of his desires no matter how
sick and twisted they were he was
enabled to be stopped due to the power
that he possessed and the fact that
Jessica managed to break free from his
control symbolized the feminist movement
as a whole I was a testament to her
character Krysten Ritter who plays the
titular heroes stated that real women
come up to me on the street in tears
because this is the first time that they
felt represented by a lead it made them
feel so much better about their own
dramas this shows just how powerful the
show is and that at its core it follows
the theme that women are just as strong
as men if not stronger and don't deserve
to be reduced to subservience in order
to matter picking up on this theme is
Jessica Jones season 2 now set anytime
amongst a flurry of sexual misconduct
allegations in Hollywood its metaphors
are a lot more prevalent throughout the
season jessica is hounded by males in
position of power
her landlord hates her her
superintendent wants her evicted and
there's a monster stalking her every
move the show questions what does sexual
assault mean and what does it do why
does it leave the wrong person ashamed
and everybody silent a new villain who
wants to take over a business states
that he doesn't take no for an answer to
which Jessica replies how rapey and this
marks out new terrain the show is saying
that things that have always been said
should now crash headlong into things
that are never said and it adds a
breeding ground for discussion it's very
clear that the majority of the males and
the JJ universe want women to be in
second place
and this aesthetic is put in place early
on by the fact that Jones's previous
employer insidious Harper played by
carrie-anne moss comments on how society
is always deemed her is pretty good for
a girl this speech is delivered during
an award show that Harper helped to fund
in order to gain the acclaim main prize
and whilst it could be viewed as
tactically shallow due to only being
achieved through monetary means it also
confirms that Harper is able to operate
with the same tactics that those who
oppose her to in order to gain power
making her as equal as they are going on
her own arc of self-destruction that
somewhat mirrors Jessica's downfall at
season two's core is the motif that both
characters are dealing with trauma
Jessica believed that killing kilgrave
would end her depression however it
didn't and she must learn acceptance and
growth from the fact that her past has
made her as strong as she is
Jessica's adopted sister Patsy to
symbolizes the rise of powerful women
abused by a film director at 15 she is
the closest symbol of the sexual
harassment scandal that can be found in
the show throughout season 2 she comes
to realize that she is not using her
platform
Trish talks productively the radio show
becomes a place for the voiceless
together and unite stove's without
powers has one force it stands true for
feminism and depicts it as a movement
that shouldn't be ignored
to me this showcases the power of the
media and demonstrates how it can either
be used positively to empower or
silenced those that it sees as a threat
this show is a clear beacon for feminism
and it was released on International
Women's Day
it's hard to ignore just how much social
commentary that there is packed within
the 13 episodes and it would take hours
for me to divulge on every single aspect
jessica jones season 2 does an excellent
job of exceeding all of the stereotypes
that this is just another superhero show
steeped in a wealth of metaphor and
political symbolism jessica jones
remains one of the greatest comic book
TV shows ever
and definitely demands a second watch
especially in today's political climate
so thanks very much for taking the time
to watch my video it's always difficult
dealing with such controversial themes
as presented in the show so I hope that
didn't cause any offence in the way that
I presented my argument I'd love to hear
your thoughts on season 2 so please
leave a comment below telling me whether
it lived up to your expectations or if
you feel disappointed in some way if
you're interested in comic books then
check out my interview with John Higgins
colorist of The Watchmen and The Killing
Joke our chat was an in-depth look at a
medium as often I was shadowed in comic
books and it provided a lot of intrigue
to the work that John has been apart he
can also subscribe to my channel by
clicking my avatar I produce videos
analyzing movies TVs games and comic
books weekly and they'll definitely be
something on the channel that you like
again thanks for checking out my video
and I'll see you next time take care
peace